şu an yapay zekasını günlük hayatımızda
bizim çok içimizde çok yanımızda Yapay
Zeka seviyoruz Onun bize sundukları
ndanda memnunuz Evet işimizi
kolaylaştırıyor ve bize hızlandırıyor e
Bunlar çok güzel Hatta Yapay Zeka sayısı
daha çok eğleniyoruz daha çok bir araya
gelemiyoruz sağlığımıza Gözetliyor Yapay
Zeka bugün Yapay Zeka tabanlı bir takım
uygulamalar ve cilt kanserine normal
klasik yöntemlere göre çok daha üstün
bir şekilde teşhis edebiliyor teşhis
etmede ki verimlilik oranının 198 lerin
üzerinde eve diğer kanser tiplerinde
veya az aynı hastalığında da erken
teşhisi ortaya koyabilme e konusunda
klasik tıbbın toprağı üzerine çıkmış
durumda 191 Aşan Bir etkinliği var
Dolayısıyla bizim karşımıza bu kadar
güzel fırsatlar sunan bizim sağlığınızı
düşünen çok daha kaliteli bir hayat
sürmenizi çok daha eğlenceli bir hayat
sürmenizi sağlayan ve çok sevdiğim
Evet Ee çok memnun Olduğumuz bu yapay
zekayı Aslında aklımızı kurcalayan bir
soru yüzünden coşkuyla ve istediğimiz
şekilde kucaklıyoruz Yapay Zeka
dediğimizde aklımıza gelen ilk soru ve
herkesin sorduğu en önemli soru Yapay
Zeka geliştikçe bize rakip mi olacak ilk
önce işlerimiz elimizden alacak sonra
biz altılı hale getirecek bir gün
geldiğinde bize ortadan kaldırmaya mı
kalkacağım şu anda kutu gibi görünse de
aslında kuzu postun altında zamanı
bekleyen bir kurt mu Yapay Zeka bu Sonra
cevabı değil ama öngörülerde
bulunabilmek için ilk önce yapay zekayı
tanımlamamız gerekiyor yapay zeka nedir
Bir Yapay Zeka tanımadan önce ilk önce
zekayı tanımlamamız lazım zeka nedir
zeka ile ilgili bugüne kadar belki
binlerce Belki yüz binlerce tanım
yapıldı bu takımların hepsi Evet zeka
ile ilgili bir takım ve çağrışımlar
yarattı Biz de ama bugün itibariyle de
en çok kabul edilen ve en genel geçer da
da zekayı şu şekilde tanımlıyoruz
ardışık hedeflere ulaşabilme abiye tipi
çabuk Hanım yaptığımız hepimizin aklında
bu kabiliyetler ile ilgili bu karmaşık
hedeflerle ilgili bilgisi de belirliyor
kendi kendine giden araçlar araç
kullanabiliyor satranç oynayabiliyor
Evet başka neler yapabiliyor acaba bir
takım problemler programlama yapabiliyor
mu gitti de birtakım karmaşık Elif'le
böyle istedim sadece entelektüel
olanları değil duygusal olanları da var
insanlarla ilişki kurabiliyor mu
konuşabiliyor bir sohbet yaratabiliyor
mu gibi kabiliyetleri aklımıza geliyor
Bunu listesini yapabiliriz Ve
çoğaltabiliriz Fakat bu konuda
Avustralya lı bir robotik ile yapay zeka
araştırmacısı mor Eko güzel bir Metafor
yapmış bu ne kadar üzerinden gidersek
Aslında o bu listeyi çok daha güzel bir
şekilde anlama şansımız ve anlamlandırma
şansımız olur metafora Moralin
kabiliyetler manzarası diyoruz şimdi Bu
metaforun amorat ne yapmış bir göl
manzarası
bu üzerinde birtakım tepeler ve bu
tepelerin yükselen dağlarla devam ettiği
bir görüntü var bu tepelerin bazılarını
da isimler vermiş ve Aslında mor Evet bu
da bize şunu gösteriyor Bu tepelerin
yükseklikleri arttıkça bu bahsettiğimiz
kabiliyetlerin karmaşıklığı da
yükseliyor baktığımızda Buradan en kısa
tepelerin isimlerinde alışkanlık edinme
var bu birazcık hafızayla ilgili size
aritmetik var gördüğünüz bir Hesap
makineleri onlarca yıldır hayatımızda
Evet satranç oyna ve İnsanlar yeni video
Yapay Zeka tabağını satranç onlar Hatta
go'da bile insanların geliyor konuşma
tercümanlık yapma Hatta araç sürme bile
yapay zekanın E şu andaki bu alçak
tepeleri arasında kabul ediliyor tepeler
yükseldikçe sosyal iletişim yönetim
teorem kanıtlama programlama Yapay Zeka
tasarımı ve gördüğünüz gibi en yüksek
iki zirvede bilim ve sanat yapıp doluysa
mor ettim bu kabiliyetle haritasına
baktığımızda en yüksek izin verdi
16 görüyoruz aşağı doğru da indiğimiz
zaman bugün Yapay Zeka kullanarak
birçoğunun üstesinden geldiğimiz
kabiliyetleri görebiliyoruz ile bu
Metafor da bir Öyle daha var bu da nedir
bu da bu tepelerin altındaki Göl bu
göldeki suyun seviyesi Mor ve göre şu
anda yapay zekanın yapabildiği
ulaşabildik kabiliyetleri gösteriyor
video ki bu suyu seviyesi yavaş yavaş
yükselecek ve bu tepelerin bazılarını
yavaş yavaş un altında bırakmaya
başlayacağım şimdi Bununla ilgili
birazcık da araştırmayı genişletmek ve
buradaki kabiliyetleri ile ilgili takım
öngörülerde bulunmak için araştırmacılar
yapay zekayı kategorize etmeye
çalıştılar Aslında en çok gene kabul
gören çeşitleme yi en basit bakış
açısıyla yaptılar bu fonksiyonellik ten
ziyade yapay zekanın yapabilir ile
ilgili bir kategorinin yaratma şeklinde
oldu dolayısıyla Bu bakış açısı diyor ya
şu anki ait bir tanesi dar Yapay Zeka
ikincisi genel Yapay Zeka timore
haritasında da gördüğünüz kabiliyetler
den sadece bir tanesini yapabilir Yapay
Zeka uygulamasına dair Ya farzet Yani
yani satranç oynama oynama araç sürme o
kadar Yapay Zeka odaklandığı konuyu
yaparken insandan daha iyi yapabiliyor
Fakat bunun ağacını başka bir şey yapma
başka hiçbir faaliyet diyor hep bir
kabiliyet genel Yapay Zeka ise insanın
sahip olduğu bütün kabiliyetlere sahip
Yapay Zeka anlamına gelir Yani oradaki
bu haritasındaki bütün tepeleri kapsayan
bütün tepeleri suların altında bırakan
ve bunların hepsini kendi içinde
barındıran zekaya genel Yapay Zeka
diyoruz şimdi başta sorduğumuz uzun
hukuk mu kuzu postu giymiş kurutma bu
sorunun cevabını aramak için aslında
önünüzde daha kritik veya daha basit
bir soru var Bunlardan bir tanesi acaba
Bir gün gelecek more in bu manzarasında
ki Göl bütün bütün bu tepelerin üzerine
aşacak Bunun cevabı evetse O halde ne
zaman insanlar bu sorunun cevabı ile
ilgili 4 ayrılıyorlar dört tane grup var
Bu nedenle farklı fikirler
alabiliyorsunuz Bunlardan birincisi
tekno kuşkucular Tek kuşkucular şunu
söylüyorlar diyorlar ve teknoloji
görüyoruz Teknoloji çok hızlı ilerliyor
çok da ilerleyecek Fakat bu da bir gün
gelecek takılacak ve teknolojide kendini
tekrar etmeye başlayacak Dolayısıyla
Onlara göre genel yapay zekayı insan hiç
zaman geliştirebilecek yani ortaya
konulan herhangi bir Yapay Zeka
uygulaması tamamiyle İnsanı sinir etmeyi
Başaramayacağım Burası Onlara göre
herhangi bir sorun yok 2 gruplu diplere
bulutlar bir sanayi devrimi sırasında
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam noting anda
bu Eğer bu yeni yeni ortaya çıkan
makineleşmiş ve mekanize edilmiş Tekstil
fabrikalarını basan bu makineler işimizi
elimizden alacak diyerek bu makineleri
gram ekibin bugün yapay zekaya yönelmiş
olan E bir parçası ve asla aynı
kişilerle onların aile hesapları değil
Onun ailesinden gelen kişiler değildir
ama aynı bakış açısını Yapay Zeka için
kuruyorlar ve onlar diyorlar ki çok az
zaman kaldı Yapay Zeka gelecek işimizi
elimizden alacak işimizi elimizden
almakla kalmayacak dünyayı daha güzel
olacak bir gün bizi yok etmek için
karşımıza dikilecek Dolayısıyla Yapay
Zeka bir an önce yasaklanma bir üçüncü
grup ise bir kopyacılar ütopyacılar
diyorlar ki genel Yapay Zeka Bu yüzden
içinde mutlaka geliştirildi insan
başarır Fakat bu da Korkacak bir şey yok
çünkü bir top yazılara göre bu sınırlı
birinci hapsolmuş İnsan zihni Yapay Zeka
sayesinde özgürleş
bu Onlara göre bu yüzyıl içinde ortaya
çıkacak olan geliştirecek olan genel
Yapay Zeka sayesinde insana çok güzel
bir gelecek Bey bir dörtlü Grup ise
yararlı Yapay Zeka acılar Bu grubun
içinde Aslı bütün diğer gruplara
bakarsak çok daha fazla akademisyen var
Bu işle ilgili çok daha fazla araştırma
yapan Bu işin içinde bizzat yer alan
insanlar var yani sayısal olmasa bile
özgül ağırlık açısından en ağır basan
Grup bu e Bunlarda kopyacılar da aşağı
yukarı zamanlama konusunda aynı şeyi
düşünürler Onlara göre bu izledik Bu
yüzden içerisinde belki birazcık daha
sürebilir bu mutlaka genel Yapay Zeka
geliştirecek ama top yazılan
ayrıldıkları bir nokta var Onlar yapay
zekanın Bir gün gelip gerçekten kuzu
postunu çıkarıp karşımıza bir kurt
olarak getirme potansiyeline sahip
olduğunu düşünüyor videolar ki bu kurdu
en hızlı şekilde bugünden
bu birleştirmeye başlamanın yollarını
aramalıyız yapay zekanın insana Yararlı
işler yapması bir insana zararlı
işlerden uzaklaşması insanın
felaketinden veya insan hayatının
varlığına et haline gelecek çalışmaların
bir birtakım Evrensel standartlarda
denetim altına alınması ve bunlara
standartlar getirilmesi gerektiğini
savunuyorlar ve bu konuda çalışıyorlar
Peki bütün bu ha 4 grubunda yapay zeka
ile ilgili ve yapay zekanın gelecekte
insanın karşısına nasıl bir görüntü ve
çıkacağı ve bu görüntüyle çıkacağı günü
ne zaman geleceği ile ilgili dört farklı
grubu ne fikirlerine ani en özel şekilde
en damıtılmış haliyle bu şekilde
açıklayabilirim Şimdi sizlere de bu
gruplardan bazıları kendinizi yakın
hissediyorsunuz eki ben de düşünüyorum
Bunlar gibi bir kere genel yapay zekanın
mutlaka bir gün geliştireceğini
düşünüyorum Evet
ne var Yapay Zeka acılara Katılıyor
yapay zekanın insanın karşısına onun
varlığını tehdit eden ilk kurtularak
dikilme potansiyeli olduğuna kesinlikle
İnanıyordum Fakat bu Dikler gibi yapay
zekaya saklanmalıdır kesinlikle deniyor
Dolayısıyla burada gözlüklerden
ayrılıyorum tekme kuşkucular da aynı
fikirde değilim çünkü onlar hiçbir zaman
da olmayacak diyorlar bana göre bu
olacak bu yüzden içerisinde Vera veya
birazcık da geçeceğim zamanlı mı
istersin ama insan mutlaka kendisini
Sibel edilen bir genel yapan zekayı
yaratabilecek genel yapay zekalı
geliştirebiliriz Dolayısıyla ekmek
hırsızlardan da ayrılıyorum yani mor
Ekin görünüm gün gelip bu Manzarada
gördüğümüz bütün zirveye ettim üzerini
kaplayacak bu manzarayı suya bakacağım
sürebileceğini ben de düşünüyorum
ütopyacılar ve yapay ve yararlı Yapay
Zeka acılarda farklı açtım bir bakış
açım var
bu tamamıyla onların görüşlerine
katılmıyorum ve bu da benim bakış açım
farklılaştıran şey şu Yapay Zeka ne
kadar gelişirse gelişsin genel Yapay
Zeka ortaya Çıksa bile Hiçbir zaman
insana üstünlük sağlayacak burada bir
çelişki var gibi görüyorsunuz Çünkü bir
taraftan diyorum ki genel Yapay Zeka
insan geliştirebilecek bütün bu tepeler
suyun altında kalacak E peki o zaman
nasıl insana üstünlük sağlayacak bunu
açıklamasında şöyle getiriyorum Ben
diyorum ki mor Ekin manzarasında eksik
zirveler var Bu da üç tane Zirve var ki
Yapay Zeka ne kadar gelişirse gelişsin
bu üç sil ve açması mümkün olmayacak Ve
insanoğlu bu zirveleri üzerinde kalarak
her zaman bu gezegenin kaderini
belirleyen hakim varlık olmaya devam
edecek more then haritasında eksik olan
bu üç tane Zirve angileri Birincisi o
elektrik insanoğlunun
de bir tane çok mu hiç birisi var
Bunlardan bir tanesi hayatta kalma
içgüdüsü Diğeri ise soydun devam ettim
içgüdüsüne ve İnsanoğlu hayatta kalma ve
soyunu devam ettirme konusunda karşına
bir tehtit çıktığında ne kadar
birbirinden ayrı bile olsa tek bir vücut
tek bir yumruk haline gelen mi
başarabiliyor dağınık halde duran
damlacıklar bir araya gelerek koskoca
bir Okyanus bir insan oğlu bir kolektifi
zeka Okyanusu aile dönüşe biliyorlar
tarihte bunun çok fazla örneği var ama
çok geçmişe gitmeden birkaç Örnek vermek
gerekirse 19'uncu yüzyılın sonlarında
başlayan kimya devrimi en çok büyük
keşifler yapıldı Kimya ile ilgili
Hayatımda çok yeni malzemeler girdi ve
İnsanoğlu ilk yaptığı şeylerden bir
tanesi bunlardan ciddi imha silahları
öğretmek oldu zehirli gazlar ettiğini ve
insanlar bunu elini Dünya Savaşı çok
aktif olarak kullanılan İki Dünya Savaşı
bir kısmı da gene bunlardan Fakat burada
insanoğlunun örnektir
Ben Yusuf alettir zekası bir araya
gelerek bunlara çok ciddi standartlar
getirdi ve şu an itibariyle baktığımızda
kimya tamamı ile insanoğlunun yararına
çalışan bir bilim dalı olarak bizim
yanımızda yer alıyor nükleer teknolojide
aynı hikaye anlatayım Biz belki birkaç
on yıl daha sonra oldu ama yükler
teknoloji ile ilgili insan olmuş yaptı
İki tane atom bombası oldu fakat Karayip
prizinde Bir küresel nükleer savaşta
karşı karşıya kaldıkları ve bunun bütün
İnsanoğlu yok etmek gibi bir sonuca
gideceğim İnsanoğlu gördüğü zaman
bununla ilgili çok ciddi standartları
oluşturmaya başladı bugün bunların
denetlendiği ve gitgide ortadan
kaldırıldı ve nükleer teknoloji Sadece
insanlar abisi çalışması gerektiği
ortaya koyan uluslararası Evrensel
birtakım anlattılar var E çok geriye
gitmeyelim 1990'ların sonunda e hepimiz
Aslında biz eve böyle bir kâbusa
sürükleyen haberle karşılaştık
Ne haber ne diyordu Ozon tabakası
derinde olan Ozon tabakası yırtıldı bu
saçı İnsanoğlu içinde bütün gezegenimiz
İçin bir tehdit haline dönüştü fakat
insanlar O gene Kolektif sağduyu
Kolektif zekalı bir araya getirerek
Bununla ilgili çok hızlı tedbirlerini
aldılar ve bugün de mutlu görüyoruz ki
Ozan tabaka mız doğru olması gereken
kalınlığına ulaşma konusunda da
ilerliyor Burada şunu söylemem gerekir
Darısı küresel ısınmanın başına Aslında
Kolektif zeka ve Kolektif Sağduyu ile
ilgili söylemek istediğim şu e burada
yararlı Yapay Zeka acılara yapmaya
çalıştım asla doğal olarak ortaya
çıkacağını öngörüyor onlar Bugünden
itibaren çalışmaya başlamak istiyorlar
buna saygı duymak lazım ama bunlar Bugün
yapılmasa bile insanoğlu bu tekstil
karşısında kaldığında mutlaka Kolektif
zekalı kuvvetli sağduyu doğal olarak
insanı yapısında var olarak ortaya
çıkacak Üçünüzü yememiz duygusal
aptallık şimdi diyeceksiniz zekâdan
ve temiz bir konuşma aptallığı yeri
nedir acaba biz bu duygusal zeka adamı
bahsediyoruz kesinlikle duygusal zekâdan
bahsetmiyoruz Çünkü duygusal zeka mor
Ekin manzarasında suların altında
kalacak kabiliyetler den bir tanesi
hatta Ve bugün bile baktığımız zaman
karşısındakinin duygularını tespit eden
bunları tanımlayan ve buna göre strateji
üreten bir takım yapay zekaya
uygulamaları var burada bahsettiğim
aptallık ve insanı Yapay Zeka dan
ayrılacak olan farklı bu haftalığına
altında yatıyor yapay zekayı Siz Aptalca
bir davranış yapmaya ikna edemezsiniz
mümkün değil Çünkü ozic insan en zeki ve
al Fakat aynı zamanda duygusal kalmasını
içinde aptallıklar da gösterebiliyor
insan aşık olur aşırıya mantıksız ca
sever dağları deler kendini herkesin
feda eder ben ölürüm Vatan sağ kalırdı
her şeye rağmen cesaret eder gemileri
yakar E sabah kitaba sığmayan iste
bu inat eder vazgeçmez Umutsuzca Sebat
eder sabır gösterin taş çatlar insan
çatlamaz insanlar büyük ilerlemeler ve
başarılar getiren birçok olayın
arkasında mantıklı değil Tamamen
duygusallıkla alınmış yapay zekanın
aptalca edici kararlar yapar Bu da
insanı Üstün varlık yapar 3. zirveniz
ise öngörülemez yaratıcılık yapay
zekanın yaratıcılığı ona verdiğiniz
bilgiler ve bağlantılarla sınır ona
dünyada var olan bütün bilgileri bile
verseniz Bu da sonuç itibari bir sınır
bir fakat insan doğduğu günden itibaren
öğrendiğim için her şey deneyimlediği
bütün her şey bütün bunları bir yere
koyarsanız ve burada bir matematik model
kurup bu İnsanın yaratıcılığını
sınırları bu deseniz bile insan bu
sınırın çok dışına taşan bir yaratıcılık
gösterme potansiyeline sahip günlük
ayakkabı çok sık görürüz insanların Ya
abi Nereden çıktı bu dediğimiz
bağlantıyı nasıl
değil Belki hayatında hiç görmediği bir
takım çağrışımlar yaratarak karşınıza
yaratıcı fikirlerle gelmiş olan
insanlara şahit olmuştur insan
Yüzyıllardır Dünya üzerinde atalarının
yaşadıkları sonucunda genetiğine işlemiş
bilgilerle doğar sadece yaşarken
öğrendikleri değil ve birkaç aylık
bebeğe örümcek resmi gösterdiğinde
korktuğunu köstebekleri büyüdüğünü
görürsün eline bir elma verdiğinizde
ağzına götürür Tüm bu kadın bilgiler
bazen sezgilerimiz olarak bize
midemizden sesimiz Derya Buradan git
Burası iyi ve bu da İçine sinmeyen bir
şey var burada dur dolayısı atalarımızı
yaşamış olduğu bir durum Bizde hiç
yaşamadığımız bir çağrışım yaratabilir
Bu da öngörülemez bir yaratıcılık olarak
ortaya çıkar Kısaca bana sorarsanız
insan er ya da geç yapay zekayla Nuh'un
gemisine bindirerek yenilik de evreni
kestireceğim güzel ve bilgelikle dolu
bir gelecek kurmayı mutlaka başaracaktır
Edirne
O çok teşekkür ederim